so how to use your wider pivot in time
of crisis okay so let me give you a
tangible example so it makes more sense
so what I do is public speaking it's one
of the things I do but it's one of what
I do what I do is public speaking right
so if I were to pivot based on what it
limits my creativity right so I'm
pivoting based on what really my only
options are to give speeches online so
the only opportunity I have is to put on
a conference online and charge money for
tickets for people to come to my
conference online doesn't that seems
very limited and it doesn't seem
repeatable I mean how many of those
could I even do so so you don't want to
pivot on what because it limits
creativity so I'm pivoting on why so my
wise to inspire people to do the things
that inspire them so we're asking
ourselves not how do we do more public
speeches online we're asking ourselves
what ways can we take advantage of in
this modern world to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them and what
we're doing is we're going through
everything we've done and we realize we
have tons of content that we never
realized had any value to the outside
world for example we found a way to do
362 reviews for our own company we
invented it for ourselves and we do it
for ourselves well we we can share that
with other people we found a way to do
evaluations we call it perform we call
it growth and performance GNP it's super
simple one sheet way to evaluate it well
we can share that with people we're
realizing that our work the importance
of being inspired not giving a speech
the importance of being inspired is more
valuable now than ever we're doing a
book club
that's that was born out of this pivot
we're realizing that starting helping
people start their Huddle's teaching
people how to do Huddle's teaching
people how to do Huddle's because we've
been doing them for years we're a
virtual team is something we can offer
even showing up for 5 minutes or 10
minutes at the beginning of someone's
huddle is something we can offer so you
can see I'm poor we're pouring with
ideas and by the way these aren't all my
ideas these came from the team but the
point is is because we're pivoting based
on what we believe to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them we're
finding lots of opportunities that we
can bring to life in a digital
world but if I pivoted based on what
it'd be all over and I and I see that
happening all over the place which is
companies are trying to like go back to
the question about Aruba like how do we
do tourism now you don't you don't do
tourism now the question is where what
is your why and how do you how do you
bring that to life in a world where
there is no tourism that's gonna yield a
lot of great ideas
[Music]